hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich habe heute ein grundrezept für euch
und zwar möchte ich euch zeigen wie ich
meine muffins mache einmal die
schokoladige variante und einmal die
helle variante
das rezept ist jetzt für zwölf muffins
und mit diesen muffins könnt ihr dann
später verschiedene dinge machen zum
beispiel macht ihr capex draus wenn ihr
dann noch eine creme drauf spritzt oder
ihr könnt sie einfach bunt dekorieren
und das ist so das grundrezept was ich
ganz gut finde und zeigt euch jetzt mal
kurz die zutaten
ihr braucht 150 g weiche butter 150
gramm zucker eine prise salz und etwas
vanille extrakt 260 gramm mehl 30 gramm
kakaopulver eventuell etwas milch und
ich brauche noch backpulver und natron
und wichtig ist hierbei dass alle
zutaten zimmertemperatur haben denn dann
verbindet sich das schön zu einem
glatten rührteig zuerst kommt jetzt die
butter eine rührschüssel dann gebe ich
da die prise salz mit dazu und etwas
vanille extrakt und es nämlich immer
ganz gerne weil es richtig schön nach
vanille schmeckt da ist echt dass
vanille konzentrat mit drin und eben
kein künstlicher zu sein noch der zucker
und jetzt wird es in etwa zwei minuten
richtig cremig gerührt
und wenn es dann weiß cremig ist gebe
ich noch nach und nach die eier mit dazu
die lasse ich jetzt auch ganz kurze
einführen und kann hier schon mal die
trockenen zutaten vermischen und wenn
ihr jetzt den hellen tag machen wollten
dem der stadt kakaopulver einfach 30
gramm der nähe
jetzt gebe ich hier noch einen halben
teelöffel backpulver mit rein und
viertel teelöffel natron und natron
nehme ich immer ganz gerne auch mit das
so weil der teig dann besser aufgeht das
findet ihr im bug regal auch in jedem
supermarkt unfalls ist doch nicht findet
könnte auch einfach die gleiche menge an
backpulver noch nur dazu geben
die zutaten kurz berühren und dann kennt
er die trockenen zutaten die rechnet
rhein geben
und falls ihr jetzt gleich noch benötigt
kommt auch noch ein bisschen mehr dazu
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal einem
affing backform mit papier förmchen
ausgelegt jetzt rationiert den teig das
geht am besten mit einem esslöffel ihr
könnt auch im normalen esslöffel
benutzen aber mit dem eislöffel
arbeiteten einfach sauber
hier habe ich jetzt auch bereits die
zutaten für den hellen tag stehen die
zeit für mich aber gleich denn vorher
gebe ich jetzt erstmal den nachwuchs in
den backofen bei 160 grad für ungefähr
zwanzig minuten
ihr könnt nach 20 minuten die stäbchen
probe mit dem zahnstocher machen und
wenn sie fertig sind nämlich die heraus
den herren tag habe ich jetzt schon mal
vorbereitet und den könnt ihr zum
beispiel verein mit verschiedenen aromen
wie zb zitronenschale von dem vorbild
agieren zitronen und hab dann für
drohnen cafés oder zitronen massing und
so können sie mir einfach irgendwelche
aromen mithin so finden und die backe
ich jetzt auch ganz schnell und zeige
mich dann gleich kennen und die dunklen
machen
so sehen jetzt die fertigen muffins aus
und ich setze jetzt auf eine abgeregelte
damit sie von oben und unten gleichmäßig
abkühlen können und jetzt können sie
entweder so lassen mit puderzucker
bestreuen
mit schokoglasur überziehen oder diese
häme zitronen glasur oder ihr wandelt
sie einfach um und macht jetzt haus
das war auf jeden fall ist mein
grundrezept für helle und für dunkle
macht und ich hoffe das rezept hat euch
gefallen und ihr könnt alles nochmal
nachlesen auf zehn.de und wir sehen uns
das nicht mal wieder bis ans ziel